also auf kurze distanz geknallt hat
schon etwas geht auf und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video auf das
ich mich freue
das ist doch ein format das habe ich
schon vier mal gemacht und es ist jedes
mal richtig cool angekommen ich habe
richtig viele kommentare mal vollkommen
richtig viele leute haben es gesehen
interagiert und so weiter und da blieb
für mich natürlich keine andere option
über alles ist noch mal zu machen und
deswegen habe ich schon ein bisschen
länger her 34 woche wieder einiges
bestellt einige kostenlose gadgets von
risch und von jugendwehren heute
allerdings erstmal die us kette ist weil
das sind auch die einzigen die bis jetzt
eingetroffen sind für die es nicht
können erst wahrscheinlich aber auch
nach dem titel gewesen
es geht um 10 kostenlose fischprodukte
alles sachen die ich da gefunden habe
und gestellt und besorgen
was ich aber gerade sagen muss leider
sind es doch nur neun mal eins fehlt
noch das heißt auch im titel steht
wahrscheinlich trotzdem zehn weil ihr
das so unter diesen zehn kennt so denkt
euch einfach eins dazu na gut das ganze
auch schon ziemlich lange her ist habe
ich absolut keinen plan mehr was ich da
eigentlich bestellt habe natürlich
versuchen euch dann immer den artikel
einzublenden ich hoffe ich finde ja auch
noch alle einig wird sagen wir arbeiten
uns einfach mal von oben nach unten für
weitere passiert schon mal decken dann
nach oben da und ihr wisst es ja ihr
könnt mir immer bei instagram 30 alex
wie irgendwelche produkte schicken die
ich testen solle von irgendwelchen
komischen seiten für die ihr euch
vielleicht selber interessiert aber das
geld dafür nicht ausgeben wollte bevor
wir nicht wissen ob es wirklich gut oder
nicht gut ist okay wir fangen jetzt an
genug lagert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bevor wir uns zum kurs ich habe mir
dabei folgen wir uns gedacht wir hatten
schon so oft situationen hier wo wir
keine pinzette im haushalt hatten da hab
ich mir gedacht bestellt sie doch
einfach mal ein ganzes set
hier kann man jetzt also ich hab keine
ahnung auf jeden fall haben wir jetzt so
was
mehr brauche ich dazu auch nichts was
freust du dich lieber nicht gut machen
wir mal weiter
[Applaus]
genau das ist ein adapter für fast
charting also damit lädt ein handy
doppelt so schnell wie mit einem
normalen adopter ob das stimmt also so
ganz glauben kann ich es noch nicht aber
es gibt so was es gibt so was ja gut
dann würde ich sagen ich fest dass man
im tor markus mein iphone ladekabel
das ist irgendwie ein bisschen verstört
passt gar nicht richtig so also ich
stoße das jetzt immer am anfang des
videos 3 prozent geladen
dann schauen wir mal am ende des videos
und dann kann ich eine einschätzung
geben ob das jetzt schneller war
langsamer oder gleich so eine sache
und dann sage ich auch als mehr zum
produkt wir machen weiter
das hat das dann weißt du was das ist
sie bestellen genau jetzt kann man nicht
mal hier ganz entspannt wenn wir wieder
kochen die gurken und zu schälen
also wir hatten schon mal so was
ähnliches in diesem küchengerät schutz
ich würde sagen dass taucht einiges also
kann man mit arbeiten weil das was wir
in den küchen der tus hat jetzt schon
mal so vision küchen gerd schütz
getestet das waren rein
das konnte nichts jetzt schon auf tour
nach burg am bohle halt dein maul okay
machen wir weiter
nächstes produkt war das ist das
wichtigste das habe ich schon gesehen
ich weiß was es ist hast du eine ahnung
was das sein könnte
hashtags race for future save the planet
[Musik]
wir haben hier verschiedene arten von
strohhalmen zum beispiel einmal hier den
gummi strohhalm dann einen hauskanal
metall oder so und das gleiche nochmal
das heißt du musst nie wieder ein
plastiks räume nutzen wenn du dir jetzt
für mcdonald's irgendwas holst kannst du
sagen bitte ohne schuhe in den habe ich
zu hause und wenn das jeder auf der welt
machen würde wenn man schon ein
stückchen weiter oder viel spaß also ich
finds wirklich cool und das kann sich ja
jeder idee bestellen und hat dann halt
so ein und braucht man halt keine
klassik strom mehr nach oben machen wir
weiter
nächstes produkt das will ich am ende
machen sondern
kann man diesen china chance
die betreiben so krankes marketing want
to try aber nur items for free das habe
ich jetzt schon kostenlos bei denen
geschossen nur versand halt und jetzt
wollen sie mir noch eins andrehen gar
nicht mehr genau was das hier war ich
gebe mal da ich gehe mal davon aus das
ist für ein smartphone
wir können ja mal ganz kurz nachschauen
du tactical welt funny face pastor autor
cycling von pakit kommt das handy rhein
alles mögliche was mit dem handy zu tun
hat weißt du das ist was für richtige
abenteuer wie für mich also da habe ich
einen richtigen schnapper gemacht gut
versand drei euro aber die qualität
davon ist ganz neues also schlecht ist
das nicht also an alle die so etwas
brauchen gibt es kostenlos beim ich
müsste den versand bezahlen 3 euro
hätten aber geiles ding also qualität
gefällt mir wohl so mache weiter kommen
wir haben jetzt bei produkte die sind
ungefähr gleich groß und auch ungefähr
gleich schwer die wegen eigentlich gar
nichts ich habe absolut keine ahnung was
sei es dann ist kann natürlich auch sein
dass das irgendwie so nachzügler ist von
eis aus produktnummer so weiß ich nicht
aber das wollen wir herausfinden
[Musik]
es ist nicht ich weiß was ist das ist
einfach ein mini fein und bogen set für
zahnstocher warte mal und das kann man
jetzt natürlich eben versuchen
zusammenzubauen
2000 jahre später leute wir haben dieses
mini dingen niveaus bambus xxl ist jetzt
einfach ein zahnstocher hier rein
das war ein ganz genau kann das zusammen
zu prickeln also eigentlich eine geile
erfindung der zahnstocher kommt jetzt
gefordert durch
aber auch das geht schon alter mit der
theoretisch dann kannst du einem das
ausschießen weiß mal gucken wie
weiterkommt megageil es geht also
[Musik]
also drei meter sagen wir mal
aber das war witzig ich hatte dies teil
aber eigentlich ein bisschen größer
eingeschätzt
naja gut machen wir weiter das ist bis
jetzt das beste macht spaß was war das
denn nochmal ich habe es eben doch
gesehen dass ist dass wir kurz gucken
federn halt einfach so goldfedern ich
weiß gar nicht mehr warum ich die
bestellt haben können es einmal auf ja
also eigentlich nicht verrückt was kein
mensch ist halt so vielleicht so eine
deko sache aber ganz ehrlich kommt um
länglich anm eine armbrust hier dran und
das hier da war ich mir auch nicht mehr
sicher ich glaube das ist einfach auch
nur ein band für nur um als eine hohe zu
befestigen oder so eigentlich hatte ich
gedacht ist es dann sport am band aber
da habe ich mich vor geschnitten an da
nicht die sowas brauchen gibt es
kostenlos bei wollte nur sagen das waren
jetzt die neuen produkte die ich für das
heutige video hatte es kommen noch viel
kohle seid bitte nicht enttäuscht ich
bin ein bisschen enttäuscht
außer die armbrust hier war alles
scheiße na gut nicht ganz scheiße aber
wir hatten schon bessere teil sag mal so
richtig auf jeden fall an falls wir noch
nicht gesehen habt wir schießen jetzt
sowie ein bisschen mit den veranstaltern
durch die gegend ohne sehen uns dann
morgen um 19 uhr wieder da gibt es
nämlich ein neues video
haut rein warte dein moment instagram
alex w also auf kurze distanz knaller
schon